We have to go back to where it all started
so they never do that to anyone again
we're a family we fight with you
you won't win i've always found it best
not to look into the past
okay you got a plan or shall i just stay dug and
go my plan was to drive us away well your plan sucks
at some point we all have to choose between
what the world wants you to be who you are
i made my choice
i'm done running
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
black widow trailer video disney finally confirmed
that they are going to drop it on disney plus so
i'll explain the plan with that how it's going to
change things they rescheduled a couple movies
but it's not as bad as it sounds also explain
how black widow is connected to some of the marvel
disney plus series like falcon and winter soldier
and it's going to overlap with the loki episodes
as well with its new release date so i'll explain
how that's all connected if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're in the middle of falcon and winter
soldier episodes right now that's going to run for
the next couple of months and careful for spoilers
from falcon and winter soldier episode 1 if you
haven't seen that yet because i'll be talking
about some easter eggs that show up during that
but what's going to happen with the black widow
movie is that disney plus is releasing it on july
9th for an extra 30 like the disney premier access
like riot in the last dragon movie but it'll also
be coming out in theaters on the same day so in
july most theaters will probably be open again
around the world you can choose how you want
to watch the movie if you want to go see it in
a theater or if you want to watch it in your home
and pay an extra 30 but after that pretty much all
the rest of the marvel movies for the rest of 2021
into 2022 will just be coming out in theaters like
they regularly would so the new schedule now is we
have black widow coming in july then shang chi was
delayed just a couple months to september venom 2
is coming in october eternals is still in november
that's not moving spider-man 3 no way home is
still coming out in december that's not moving
either so really the only big changes here
are that the black widow movie in shanghai
just moved a couple months not a huge deal
so now black widow is going to overlap with
the loki episodes on disney plus in july i can't
count the number of people who have asked if this
woman in the loki trailer is black widow sitting
on vormir because the sky looks all purple like
the skies of vormir yes the disney plus series
will cross over and influence the marvel movies
but no this is not black widow natasha black widow
this is a version of female loki from an alternate
timeline alternate universe she's being played by
this actress here so i think it's just the fact
that she's really blurry and she has blonde
hair the people think that she's black widow
the loki series is a time travel multiverse series
where he has to go around capturing alternate
versions of himself alternate loki's from other
realities to stop them from messing with alternate
timelines they've started to release more clips
and trailers for that recently but the scene that
everybody keeps asking about this female loki
scene this is her sitting on a future version of
earth that just completely gone to crap because of
what she's been doing the whole idea if you watch
the loki trailer you notice that it seems like
all these different versions of earth just wind
up in complete disaster like you see the rubble
of the avengers tower in the background here like
what has happened in this alternate timeline with
this version of loki to lead to this and it's the
tesseract loki that's wearing the jacket here that
you see drop down that has to go around stopping
the alternate versions of himself like who better
to take down loki than another version of loki
it's just that these alternate versions like
female loki the other loki's they're all way worse
than the tesseract loki the whole thing with the
black widow movie is that per scarlett johansson's
explanation during interviews last year the movie
is supposed to be her metaphorically passing the
torch to florence pew passing the mantle of the
black widow of the mcu to the elena belova black
widow technically they're all black widows
even rachel weiss's character molina vostakov
taskmaster revives the program in the movie and
is training a batch of new black widow assassins
under his command it's just that in the future
marvel movies marvel phase 4 the disney plus
series that she crosses over into yelena belova
will be the new main black widow we'll see how
the other characters interact with her because
they've already confirmed the next crossover for
her is going to be the hawkeye series and that's
going to be happening later this year in the fall
you just have to imagine how she's going to react
when she finds out that hawkeye let black widow
sacrifice herself on for me are like what you let
her kill herself how dare you i do not think that
she's supposed to cross over on falcon and winter
soldier though but there is some crossover story
and connections between falcon and winter soldier
in the black widow movie in present day the black
widow movie mostly takes place in the past because
natasha is dead in present day after avengers end
game and there's no secret plot to bring her back
to life or reveal some weird face swap situation
where somebody else sacrificed themselves on
former not going to bring her back in present
day but they did say that they might do more black
widow stories more black widow movies potentially
set in the past if they ever decided to bring
her back but it would all be flashback stuff
this movie mostly takes place right after captain
america civil war and the main story at least the
just the main portion of it ends just before
the beginning of avengers infinity war there
are probably some more flashbacks to her as a
little girl coming up through the red room program
just to tell her origin story and then there's
some implied post-credit scenes stuff some rumors
that will be taking place in present day so the
movie is going to hop around in the timeline but
for the most part it takes place between civil war
and infinity war it'll also explain all the family
talk during the trailer too there's the story
about them being a family that takes place before
the events of the black widow movie that i'll talk
about and there's the budapest stuff that she and
hawkeye kept referencing in the avengers movies
they'll also cover that stuff too but mostly the
story is her just going back to russia because
she learns taskmaster has restarted the black
widow program and she wants to stop that from
happening and just part of her going back to her
original home in russia is dealing with all the
past trauma that she experienced in the red room
all the red on her ledger she's finally dealing
with that the same way the scarlet witch finally
had to deal with her own reckoning with her
past and her trauma in the Wandavision episodes
so they're doing the same thing for natasha in the
black widow movie that they did for scarlet witch
in the Wandavision episodes except scarlet witch
isn't just going to go off to doctor strange 2
in a hot minute and die yes it should go without
saying that they should have released the black
widow movie way back during marvel phase 2 right
after they introduced her character in iron man 2
but the connection in present day with what's
happening on falcon and winter soldier is just
rumored to be thunderbolts setup and possibly
the weapons plus super soldier serum storyline
like we just met the new dark captain america
john walker aka u.s agent from the comics he
was given a deluded version of the super soldier
serum just like thunderbolt ross gave abomination
during incredible hulk weapons plus is just what
thunderbolt ross renames the super soldier program
when he restarts it except now he's just using
more experiments different types of treatments
to enhance soldiers in addition to giving them
that lesser version of the super soldier serum
during the black widow trailer they introduced red
guardian aka red hopper from stranger things he's
the soviet version of captain america from the
comics he was also given a similar copy of the
super soldier serum back during the cold war when
the soviets started the black widow program after
world war ii eventually they started giving all
the graduates the women who survived the program
diluted forms of the super soldier serum just like
red guardian so at least in the comics black widow
does have some super strength she's not as strong
as captain america but she's way stronger than a
normal human which explains how it's easy for her
to run around with the avengers and hold her own
so there's a rumor that in the black widow movie
taskmaster has gotten his hands on a version of
that diluted super soldier serum and he's to
start dosing up the new black widow candidates
turning them into his army of killing machines
just like you saw the hydra super soldiers during
the captain america civil war movie but just to
be clear hydra was completely separate from the
black widow program so while all this stuff with
winter soldier in this secret hydra base way up
in siberia is happening inside the soviet union
during the cold war all the stuff with the black
widow program natasha's black widow all that was
being done by a completely separate group inside
the soviet government if you watch the agent
carter tv series with peggy carter's character
they did actually include some flashbacks to the
origin of the black widow program so maybe we'll
see a little bit of that during the black widow
movie the whole thing going on with the family
that they have going on here the funny moments
in the trailer is that they're not her biological
family the reason why they're calling each other
family like molina is the mother red guardian's
the father yelena belova is her sister is because
when they were all still part of the program a
long time ago they all lived in america as
spies pretending to be an american family
living in the suburbs like the american series
on fx just pretending to be regular americans
and those were all the roles that they played
within that fake family father mother sisters
but eventually i think they kind of explained
that they started to grow closer and it became
more like a real family but the whole theory with
the post-credits scenes just connecting back to
the marvel disney plus series and present day
and the thunderbolt stuff is at some time maybe
at the end of the movie or in the post-credits
scenes thunderbolt ross will offer taskmaster and
maybe yelena belova clemency on their prison
sentences for all the crimes they committed
if they work for him and they'll just sort of
use it as a reverse nick fury iron man 1 post
credit scene where he came to tease the avengers
only they'll be teasing the thunderbolts we know
that falcon and winter soldier is supposed to also
help set up the thunderbolts too with baron zemo's
character probably maybe us agent captain america
and maybe aaron kellyman's flag smasher character
we'll see how many of these brand new characters
wind up making it under the thunderbolts roster i
think it's just pick and choose depending on what
they want the team to be like in a couple years
but everyone let me know what you think about them
bringing black widow to disney plus down in the
comments in my falcon and winter soldier episode
2 video we'll post on friday just like normal
so everyone click here for my full falcon winter
soldier episode one video if you haven't seen that
yet and click here for that brand new falcon
and winter soldier episode 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!